[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
May 10th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
having a good job by age 30 can be an
important milestone in your career but
what decisions can you make in your 20s
that'll help you secure that good job or
reduce your chances of getting one wsj
workplace reporter Lindsay Ellis wrote
about some recent analysis out of
Georgetown University looking at the
path that people in their 20s take to
Landing a good job by 30. so Lindsay how
was a good job defined in this research
and why is getting a good job by age 30
so important so a good job was defined
through wages so it was the minimum
amount that was required for economic
self-sufficiency it differed from Metro
area to metro area and from rural to
urban areas and the median of the good
jobs that this team analyzed had a
salary of about fifty seven thousand
dollars the good jobs also were
important because there was correlation
between having a good job and having a
job that your employer would offer
health insurance or a 401k and
contributions there and so it goes
beyond just the minimum salary to
Encompass in many cases other benefits
as well these researchers have found
that 30 is a important Benchmark year
that if you can get a good job by 30 or
by your early 30s you have a better
chance of being in a better financial
position later in life and so this team
of researchers has really dug into these
different Pathways to get a good job by
age 30 so that people know how to
navigate some of these choices to set
themselves up for the subsequent decades
and so what was the main takeaway
regarding steps to take to get a good
job by age 30. it's a really good
question and for context so this is
coming as many Americans are skeptical
of the value of a four-year college
degree but this team analyzed
longitudinal Government research for 8
000 plus people and they found that to
get a good job the pathways that could
make the biggest difference for people
in their 20s involved College it's
pursuing a bachelor's degrees and
earning one before your mid-20s for
people who don't go down that pathway
it's pursuing a community college
program an associate's degree or a
skills certificate that the options that
involve College taking those could
improve people's chances of getting a
good job by age 30. as the competition
for workers heated up during the
pandemic we saw some companies eliminate
the bachelor's degree requirement for
hires has that Trend changed so big
companies have signaled that they are
more open to people without bachelor's
degrees and that they might pursue a
skills-based evaluation in vetting
whether you would be a good candidate
for a job or not while that rhetoric is
still there and some companies have
stuck with these policies I think it's
good to remember that the bachelor's
degree remains a significant hurdle for
many jobs even entry-level jobs that
many of these positions despite sort of
that trend of some companies moving
toward it still require the bachelor's
to get your foot in the door but is
there anything short of a four-year
degree that people can get that can help
them toward the goal of a good job in
their 30s yes so one key area is getting
an associate's degree going to community
college or kind of getting a
skills-based certificate each of those
makes a difference the Georgetown
researchers looked at the same set of
data they could isolate that decision
and found that there was a bump if you
went down those Pathways the other thing
that they found that made a difference
was that for some individuals who've
graduated high school but don't expect
to pursue a bachelor's degree if those
individuals started a bachelor's degree
that could also lead to a pretty
significant bump so they found that even
if you didn't finish for some people
starting could also make a difference
how big a bump are we talking about as
it stands right now these non-finishers
have a 40 chance of getting a good job
by 30 according to this Georgetown data
the researchers sort of isolated that
decision whether these individuals
finished college or didn't finish
college and looking at the data and they
found that if these individuals
eventually earned a bachelor's degree by
age 26 keeping every other factor in
their life constant they would have a
higher chance 56 percent of getting a
good job so that's a 16 percentage Point
difference if you can sort of hold on
and finish that degree now what if
somebody has no choice but to work
instead of going to college is there any
upside to that yes and I did talk to a
number of workers who did not go to
college or did not start out going to
college for men many reasons either when
they were in their early 20s years ago
or during the pandemic even a couple of
years ago what the Georgetown
researchers found and what some of these
people told me too is that there are
really important choices that you can be
making the first is the industry and the
type of job matter if you can work in a
high-paying field science technology or
Finance or business or the like instead
of a low paying field like food services
or Arts that can make a difference for
you if you hold that type of position in
your early 20s the other aspect is Blue
Collar work can also give a boost and
there was an effect of if you could even
keep a job between 20 and 22 that
continuous employment over those years
makes a difference for your likelihood
of getting a good job when you're 30.
now it's not uncommon for people to have
employment gaps on their resume how does
that work into being able to land a good
job so that's a great question yes
avoiding employment gaps especially in
your early 20s from 20 to 22 that makes
a difference one reason according to the
researchers is that some hiring managers
might have a stigma against hiring
someone with a resume Gap or someone who
is unemployed the other aspect of it is
just from a sheer skills development
perspective the thought being that if
you are constantly employed in those
years you will be learning and growing
and gaining new skills and that might
ultimately set you on a trajectory of
having a better job several years later
that's Wall Street Journal workplace
reporter Lindsay Ellis and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you